pour avoir des explications on en parle
avec fabien major planificateur
financier chez major gestion privée
bonjour monsieur major bonjour premières
tendances que vous avez remarqué
pour l'heure marcoussis généralement les
gens achètent de plus en plus des
actions qui sont glamour
si vous permettez l'expression comme
tesla alors que selon vous on devrait
privilégier des titres avec un rendement
qui est plus le plus régulier exactement
et c'est la grande différence en ce qu
on parle on identifie comme le style
valeur et le style croissance et ses
différents cela résulte souvent dans le
prix payé par rapport aux bénéfices des
compagnies et dans l'exemple tesla tesla
commence à faire un peu d'argent alors
que si on compare avec des grandes
banques américaines ben alors ça fait
parfois plus d'une centaine d'années
qu'elles sont rentables
les sociétés de style valeurs sont
souvent plus anciennes donc mais on va
les identifier avec le prix de l'action
qui est raisonnable et dans le cas de
plusieurs compagnies de la mort ou de
type croissance bénin on est vraiment
plus dans le raisonnable bien voulu voir
la garde est d'ailleurs un simple on
vous a préparé des données donc les deux
types d'actions donc les styles
croissance où venait tout juste d'en
parler souvent ce sont des techno alors
ça peut être amusante par exemple
facebook netflix ou tesla alors que les
actions de type valeurs ce sont des
firmes comme berkshire hathaway de
warren buffett johnson & johnson banca
bad bank of america alors vous avez déjà
commencé à répondre à la question mais
c'est quoi la différence majeure entre
les deux là la différence est que le
style croissance c'est qu'on veut tabler
sur potentiel de croissance du capital
pour une revente dans les prochains mois
ou le très court terme le style
croissance comme facebook ou des
compagnies comme une vidéo par exemple
ça c'est quand même évident mais on va
l'observer dans le ratio le ratio cours
bénéfices c'est donc le cours de
l'action sur les bénéfices des sociétés
ben pour les styles valeurs en ce moment
on a un ratio qui tout près de 10 pour
les sociétés américaines et 40 fois les
bénéfices pour les sociétés de type
croissance ou plutôt technologique mais
c'était carla moi il me fait pas parce
qu'on n'a jamais vu ça depuis 1999 soit
ya quelques mois en le crash mémorable
en mars 2000
oui on se rappelle que la bulle techno à
ce moment elle avait éclaté mais
monsieur major lorsqu'on regarde depuis
le
début de la pandémie les actions
croissance ont vraiment bien performé
par vous prépare également aussi des
données vous regardez les onze
premièrement donc s p 500 pour 1 6%
rendement depuis le début de l'année
2020 mais regardez amazon c'est plus 63%
tesla 264% alors que pour les autres
actions plus sécuritaires comme
berkshire hathaway ou bank of america on
voit plutôt des reculs
oui en effet en effet baissé c'est là
qu'on voit qu'il ya comme une
dislocation dans le marché puisque on a
d yeux que pour les sociétés
technologiques
mais attention quand on regarde le ratio
des bénéfices
on voit des choses un peu saugrenue
amazon qui se sentent 3000 dollars ces
trois races ou 244 ça veut donc dire que
l'investisseur si les ratios en fait la
rentabilité demeure la même
on retrouve son capital dans 144 1 c'est
sûr qu'il ya pas de sens mais dans les
sociétés plus terre-à-terre ben c'était
un ratio d'à peu près 10 et non ben
c'est normal
et à quand une hausse de ses actions de
type de valeurs alcoa aux bains
normalement en fin de cycle économique
ou en début d'un autre
c'est souvent caractérisée par une
récession et on on est en plein dedans
justement alors c'est pour ça qu'on
croit que l'investisseur qui a fait des
bons gains avec ces fonds ou ses actions
de cils croissance devrait empocher une
partie de ses gains et réinvestir
l'autre portion dans le style valeur à
long terme
on le regrettera pas et de diversifier
également bondi souvent d'ailleurs donc
aux investisseurs aux boursicoteurs de
diversifier finalement ses actions
oui exactement parce que la tendance
naturelle c'est de tout le temps miser
sur le cheval gagnant qui en ce moment
pourrait s'essouffler très rapidement
avoir le style valeur et croissance d'un
portefeuille ca du bon sens pour
l'investisseur à long terme très
précisément pour tesla j'ai envie de
vous justement de vous tester est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils aillent leur recul
important parce qu'on le sait
actuellement le lobby d'ailleurs on l'a
vu c'est une croissance qui est
phénoménal
oui absolument il faudrait que les
ventes puisse maintenir la cadence mais
il ya une capacité limitée de production
il ya une usine en chine qui débute
bientôt qui a commencé même à délivrer
certains véhicules
mais écoutez c'est une action qui ne
fait pas consensus
l'essai est clair que les investisseurs
sur tesla ont un billet spéculatifs oui
un dirigeant également qu'il ne fait pas
consensus mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
j'aimerais ça vous entend plus
généralement aussi sur les marchés qui
se porte très bien est ce qu'on doit
craindre cela dit une nouvelle chute
c'est possible en effet puisque
l'investisseur va être tentée de vendre
ses titres gagnants quand il ya un peu
de mauvaises nouvelles économiques et il
y en aura ça je suis à peu près certain
oui mais de quelle façon le marché va se
comporter
ça dépend beaucoup de la reprise
économique et des nouvelles
scientifiques en lien avec la découverte
de médicaments et vaccins efficaces
contre la crevette de 19 le niveau et
économique ou financier qui pourra se
prononcer mais on est vraiment reliés à
des nouvelles scientifiques et médicales
voilà exactement donc l'économie
finalement voir suivre la situation
sanitaire et vous savez on a injecté
énormément d'argent donc pour soutenir
l'économie mais on a parfois
l'impression et a donné qu'on a vu des
hausses importantes sur les marchés
boursiers on a l'impression parfois que
les marchés vivent dans un monde
parallèle est ce que la réalité
finalement vont nous rattraper
oui sans doute mais ont pu distinguer le
marché et le prix des actions c'est une
petite catégorie qui a tiré le marché
vers l'europe principalement les
sociétés de type technologique ou les
sociétés qui sont plus grenat me la main
comme on l'a identifié plus tôt ces
sociétés là donnent l'illusion que le
marché va très bien et si on les enlève
on s'aperçoit que les replis sont
toujours depuis début d'année
d'à-peu-près -12% bhl alors donc il faut
prendre le marché avec énormément de
précautions et certainement analyser ce
qu'on a dans son portefeuille les
prendre des profits c'est le conseil le
plus sage que je peux offrir un très bon
conseil voilà qui est plus que la merci
beaucoup mais ce major d'avoir été avec
nous merci au revoir